[Music]
a symphony orchestra can include more
than 100 musicians but one person is
tasked with bringing the music to life
the conductor
maestros are a paradox they stand at
center stage with their backs turned to
the audience
they don't make a sound but they produce
music from dozens of instruments
but what is an orchestra conductor and
where did this tradition come from and
what kind of audacity does it take to
interpret some of the greatest
masterpieces in western music
this great big story was made possible
by
be grim empowering the world
compassionately
[Music]
to get an idea of what a conductor does
we turn to gustavo dudamel the conductor
of the la philharmonic
the action of conducting is connecting
with the musicians
my right hand normally it gives the beat
the baton is an extension of the arm for
everybody to see and if it's a little
bit loud with my left hand i can say
less or i have to you know
do
an entrance to somebody or if i want
longer it's a combination of things i
think the conductor is not only the
person that
moves in front of an orchestra and shows
the tempo or the dynamics
it's a person that have to
guide and inspire
the orchestra conductor didn't become a
specialized role until about 200 years
ago but conducting goes back much
further the first recorded history of a
conductor was found on a greek tablet
dating back to 709 bc it described a
giver of time beating his stave up and
down in equal movements
since then the role has evolved quite a
bit in the 17th century the composer
jean-baptiste luli was known for banging
a large staff on the floor to keep time
in a fit of passion he hid his own foot
with the staff during a performance and
later died of gangrene
later in the baroque era composers like
johan sebastian bach were known for
conducting an orchestra while playing an
organ or harpsichord simultaneously
and the german conductor richard wagner
revolutionized the position in the
mid-1800s when he argued that the
conductor's role is to interpret the
music instead of just keeping time
every conductor have a different gesture
and have a different
connection with the orchestra that is
why
if you play the beethoven fifth symphony
every version is completely different
you have an idea you have a concept that
you have to bring to the orchestra you
have to take them in a journey through a
piece of music that is the kind of
things that make the action of
conducting or making music kind of
magical
at the end the main thing is the music
the rest of us we are elements
that bring that
alive
to be swimming
in that
unique and amazing
sea of sound and then to have the
privilege to be in front of an orchestra
and give a bit to them and they start
and they follow
not only the gesture but that beautiful
desire of
living the music
is the best thing in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]